Margaret Taylor green represents Georgia
in the Congress she joins us tonight
congresswoman this happened in your
state I'm just amazed by how little we
know there's this militia that kind of
floats around America and when needed
they show up and start burning buildings
and flipping over police cars and no one
knows who they are who's paying for this
how can that be
well Tucker you light it out just
perfectly and I think honestly America
is sick and tired of antifa look at what
they've done over years now just from
2020 they're responsible for nearly two
billion dollars in damage and many
people dead but the war is against the
police and the reason why is because
antifa is the ground troops of the
Democrat Party not only are they the
ground trips they breed them they raise
them and then they bail them out of jail
when they get arrested but they never
get prosecuted and that's because well
we know the truth it's the Democrats in
control and it's the establishment and
it's the unelected bureaucrats that make
no apologies for their support of antifa
well it's time to do something about
antifa and that's why I'm going to
introduce legislation to declare antifa
domestic terrorists because they need to
be taken apart we need to investigate
exactly who they are who funds them and
then we need to make sure that whenever
they come out and corrupt in violence
attacking police officers and attacking
businesses in cities like my my city in
Atlanta and Georgia we need to make sure
that they're arrested and charged with
domestic terrorism charges just like the
gbi did this past weekend enough of
antifa they are not the anti-fascists
they are the fascists and they always
show up and and they they defend
Democrat Democrat causes not only do
they attack police but they defend the
drag queens targeting our children with
drag queens story time they they go
after people when they're not vaccinated
and demand they get vaccinated and wear
masks during the so-called pandemic but
enough of antifa we've we've had it with
them and it's time to do something about
it
yeah that was kind of a tell I would say
this is the anarchist group that's for
vax mandates
how that works is that is that in the
anarchist catechism vax mandates yeah
yeah I don't think your environmentalist
trying to stop a police training center
we're not buying it it's too funny
Congressman Margie Taylor green of
Georgia thank you so much thank you
Tucker subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight